not having a safe and affordable place
to live can play a huge role in the
mistreatment of a child a unlv professor
digs deeper into housing insecurity in a
new study just published she spoke with
victoria saha this morning to talk about
the risks and what would be got what
could be done rather to combat the issue
affordable housing is a need all around
the country but studies show las vegas
is ranked as the most severe when it
comes to the affordable housing shortage
it's really hard to parent appropriately
when you don't have a safe place to
sleep a safe
stimulating environment to raise your
kids catherine marcel a unlv professor
researched the issue of affordable
housing using data from princeton
university which included a 15-year
study which surveyed low-income moms
from 20 different cities really what
we're talking about is a lack of rental
units or homes
that
are going at rates
that low income
to middle income families can
comfortably afford in her new study
called housing insecurity and its risk
to child maltreatment marcel digs into
what the problem looks like well below
the surface living in really overcrowded
housing living in really poor quality
housing you know
rodent infestations holes in the walls
exposed wires
and and just living with really
incredible unaffordability in her study
she found a correlation between housing
insecurity and a child's risk for
physical and psychological abuse they do
not have enough money coming in to keep
up with their basic needs
that means they're only left with bad
options and when you only have bad
options you're going to make a bad
choice she emphasized that this isn't
meant to assume low-income people are
more likely to abuse their children but
how various socioeconomic factors can
contribute to maltreatment of a child
victoria saha 8 news now
now she says the affordable housing
issue can be fixed if we build more
apartments and multi-family homes as
well as put limits on short-term rentals
so they can be used by nevada residents
instead of people who are visiting